this is a production of cornell
university
hi all right i'm setting my timer for 30
minutes so that i'm
sure that i have enough time for us to
to chat afterwards and we'll see
how how quickly i flow through so
um when i sat back to think about what
we would talk about today
um i realized that the past five years
have been
sort of a stream of consciousness we
keep trying new things
and spreading out and branching and
um my my goal for the day
is to take you on this journey uh with
us that we've gone on
and at any point if you have a question
feel free to
throw it in the chat so that you don't
forget it and then maybe we can
talk about it at the end but if um if
you need clarification
if i'm going too fast if i'm using an
acronym that
um isn't familiar to everybody then by
all means
um feel free to shout out and
and stop me as i'm going um
this is essentially going to be
storytelling time for
uh for all intensive purposes i'm going
to throw a whole lot of pictures at you
and just uh describe what we've learned
as we went along i haven't
been involved with a lot of the
horticultural production until
really i would say this past year um
that's more my colleague kelly hennigan
but we
work as a team and so um
i'll let you know a bit about what we've
done and and
where we've come so uh
let's begin all right let's see if my
computer is gonna
cooperate with us there we go when i
first went to write
this uh presentation i set up the slides
for each of the years and i realized
about 15 minutes into it that i was off
by 20 years that i had written 199
1996 1997 98 99 and 2000
so apparently i'm stuck in the 1990s but
then i fixed it and realized oh no we
started growing in 2016 not 1996.
so that was our inaugural hemp crop and
um
we were partners with jd farm and at
their
farm we grew 30 acres so our our
goal was really we thought that brain
was going to be the low-hanging fruit so
we were going to focus on grain
production
that we don't really know so much about
grain production
when it comes to an organic farm and jd
farm is an organic farm
so our research focus was looking at
can we meet the nutrient requirements
for this crop
using different combinations of manures
and we figured we would just compare
yield between them as our first go
and see how we did um
that it was the craziest year for
importing
seed it was the first time around we had
no idea what we were doing
getting the seed took way longer than we
thought it was going to
the shipping company when they figured
out what they were shipping
um so they they we ordered our seed from
canada
and um it almost made it to us it made
it to syracuse and then the shipping
company realized what they were shipping
and wouldn't take it
a foot further and so i had a drive
to syracuse with police escort
um to pick up the seed sign for it
and and drive it back and then we had to
have
police watch um the seed
so that none of it was stolen between
the time when
we perched or received it until the time
it got in the ground
um and so that was crazy
so we didn't get planted until july 4th
so year one was
what we thought was a late start we
didn't get planted until july 4th
and we hired a local grain farmer to
custom harvest for us
we had no idea what we were doing it was
a really steep learning curve they had
no idea what they were doing
so we figured let's all learn together
um
and um being the the first
crop everybody wanted to get in on
pictures so even though we planted
with uh um let's get a
as you can see here um this is
uh dan dolgen and mark just
from jd farm they and we were all
planted a few this is me and my kids
we all planted a few seeds by hand uh
this was the
the truck we had to go pick up the seat
on
uh and and the police escorted back
so it was quite an exciting time um and
even though our research question was
all about nutrients
we learned a little bit about pest
pressure in that first year we learned a
whole lot about
uh weeds and that although we were
hearing lots of
people in the surrounding communities
talk about
they were concerned that cannabis sativa
would become the next
major field crop weed what we were
learning was that
this plant cannot out-compete our wheat
species
we had heard horror stories from
kentucky about
how devastating japanese beetles could
be
um and so uh we were really nervous
when we started to see some japanese
beetles on our plants but what we
realized
was that they were mostly uh
hanging out on the male flowers and
a little bit the weed species in the
field were acting as trap crops because
they were preferring being on the
pigweed around the hemp than they were
on the hemp
um so that was sort of interesting we
started learning a little bit about seed
production
and we saw uh that
what it meant for this crop to be
indeterminate and the fact that we have
our seed maturing unevenly throughout
the plant
this first year we had so many people
want to come visit the fields
and take pictures i think everybody
uh we had horticultural classes we had
ag classes we had administrators
everyone wanted to come and take a
selfie in the hemp fields
um right and so here we can see the
unevenness
of grain production we're up the top
here you can see that seeds are
are brown and drying out and um and at
the bottom
right they're still green and the
thought the first year
was oh well
if we're going to treat this like other
grain crops when we harvest our other
grain crops we wait for the seed to dry
out so we were waiting for our seed to
dry before we came through and harvested
um and another piece of this picture you
can see
the lamb's quarter here along the side
and next to it
that is uh easily as tall as the hemp
plants that were
in this field
so uh so in year one we learned a lot
about crop
variability on the left hand side is a
picture of me standing up looking down
at the crop so that's probably about
up to my knee on the right hand side is
me stretching my arm
up to reach the the crop and so maybe
that's
i don't know i'm five foot three and a
half on a good day
so maybe that's almost five foot
ten right not quite a six foot crop
there
um but we saw a whole lot of variability
in terms of height
in terms of the size of the seed head um
and in terms of the thickness of our
stock
so what we learned in um this first year
had a lot to do with what we didn't know
and that's to be expected right it's the
first time we'd ever grown this crop
um it was really exciting to learn how
many things we didn't know because
from a research perspective that just
makes you say hey what can we ask
questions about and
we figure that means that we're going to
be busy for the next
couple of years right it gives us
something to work on
right so here this was a field that was
divided into quadrants a a
there were there was half that had
um big bedded pack half that had
um beef
bedded pack manure and then um
one side had poultry litter added it too
so we were looking at combinations of
manures there
um but really we couldn't compare the
data
in these quadrants the yields because
the
weed pressure was so great that any
differences that we saw
were mostly because of the differences
in types of weeds that we saw on the
field there
but it was it was a learning experience
and fun to harvest that way anyway
okay come on any second now there we go
so year two in year two we said okay
we're focusing on green
or maybe we can figure out a dual
purpose for
using the the fiber here um we wanted
to to dial in our our nitrogen rates
and so we were starting a small plot
study on campus
and when i say small it was like a
quarter of an acre a really small plot
study on campus to do
in collaboration with what we were doing
with jd farm we were sort of
creating our grows the state had now
allowed farms to have their own permits
but then in
late may early june the governor pushed
to
have even more acres in production and
so
we threw 40 acres in on campus
that wasn't our original intention and
so
this was our opportunity to try out a
couple of different varieties
and really just get it growing because
trying to get seed that late in the game
we ended up not planting until
somewhere around july 20th right if you
remember the first year we planted july
4th
um july 20th was when we got those extra
acres in the ground and so it was a
little bit crazy
um and we hired that same
local grain farmer to to custom harvest
for us
um other than the this small quarter
acre of plots which
um i like to say my my darling slave
labor otherwise known as my students
uh you know you get a good grade for
putting in some
blood sweat and tears and so they were
in charge of doing
all of the hand harvesting of my plots
and separating out the grain
from from those plots i love them dearly
for all their hard work
so things that we learned hemp doesn't
like poorly drained or excessively wet
soil that was
the banner uh description of year number
two
um if you have poorly drained soil you
have poorly established hemp
we tried over and over and over to
establish in
june of that year our uh small quarter
acre trials we had to plant it three
times
because of how wet it was this is a
field where
you can see where it dries out on this
line the entire field was planted
but all of the field in the wet area
did not emerge so um
and you can see here there's the uh sort
of a lake
in the middle of this field june 2018
was really
wet right so um hemp does not
like poorly drained or
excessively wet soil um
and these are the the the the quarter
acre trial plots you can see the flags
are this is this would have been the
plot
that we just had to keep trying and keep
trying and keep trying to establish
because there was
so much water that was sad
um and uh you got to see my
kids in the first year this is my son
the second year i like to
show them and you can see the
progression of how they've
they've grown along with the crops
growing right so this is
the field where we were supposed to be
going through and counting emergence
and um instead we were just trying to
decide when we were going to try and
replant again because it was so
wet so um
july 7th was the third time that we
planted there and then
again two weeks later was when we
planted the rest of our fields on campus
which we decided it wasn't worth doing a
nitrogen rate trial because it was too
late we didn't even think we were going
to get a crop
um so some of the things that we learned
uh
this this year the second year was we
learned a bit about
a fusion we learned a bit about
white mold we saw that
there are definitely pests in our area
that are going to impact the crop
we saw that if hemp emerges
after a weed species that it can't
out-compete
but if the hemp emerges before a weed
species and is able to establish
then it does a whole lot better at
managing weed competition
um we saw lots more variability so these
two pictures
are the same field where
this student is about my height and the
crop
is uh up to her shoulders whereas
a hundred yards away in that same field
uh
the the crop is uh this student is a
little bit taller than me
but is up to her waist so um
we're seeing just so much variability
here and then this
is the field next to this one
and even though this picture is taken a
month later you're not getting
um much more growth after
uh flower establishment and so the fact
that this student is
six foot one so the fact that we have
this tremendous
growth here right it shows us how much
variability there is within the crop
it shows us how much um
breeding work there is to be done um to
pick out the traits that are going to
help us get
whether or not we want a shorter crop
for grain production or a taller crop
for fiber production
right that we we need to see what are
the ways that genetics can influence
crop production versus what are the
environmental influences of
of production so many questions to ask
right every every semester or every year
of a growing season we would just find
out so many more questions that we would
set out to answer one thing and then
find 15 more questions that were like oh
well before we can answer this we need
to know these things
um we we did a little bit of work
on um of indoor grows looking at
um microgreens it was sort of
interesting um
you know there there is this push for
extracts production but at the same time
we thought well
what are some other horticultural uh
ways of growing this crop
and um can a hemp micro green
compete in the micro greens market one
of the things that we
found was that while its taste and
palatability were really great
um we couldn't compete
with california right there's a reason
that the majority of microgreens are
grown in large-scale horticultural
production and not in small
boutique farms it's just too expensive
um
so we realized you know growing for
extracts is not the only horticultural
hemp crop growing from microgreens
was um really successful their
uh baby farms had a
a line of microgreens in
uh whole foods in the city for a while
um
i believe they've stopped doing that now
mostly because it's just too hard to
keep up
with the the cost of it
um okay that brings us to year three
2018.
in 2018 we grew a little bit and started
taking on partner
farms uh around the state and um
expanding our nitrogen trials so we
really were
focusing mainly on grain production with
a little bit of fiber in there but
mainly grain production
um and uh just nitrogen rates
um for answering the questions of
nutrient management we really weren't
trying to answer
questions for phosphorus and potassium
quite yet we're just focusing on
nitrogen
um there was a whole lot of drought in
june that year
and then it got really cold
and august through october were super
wet so the
combination of those things made the
growing season a little bit difficult
um we hired that same local uh grain
farmer to come harvest for us but that
was the last time that we did that
because we realized that um we were
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole
you hear a lot of people talk about
horror stories about
harvesting uh hemp for grain
think the problem is more trying to use
something outfitted for soybeans
for hemp or something outfitted for
wheat for him if we took
something outfitted for soybeans and
tried to harvest corn
we'd destroy the machine it would be
awful
right nothing good would come of that
and it's the same thing
that the issue isn't the crop the issue
is that we don't
have the equipment specified
to the crop that we're trying to harvest
now over the years we've gotten better
at that and what we found was that this
farmer that was harvesting for us wasn't
willing to
sort of learn from the things that we
were learning and
um if you always do what you've always
done you'll always get what you always
got and so he was getting
angrier and angrier at the hemp harvest
and we were getting angrier and angrier
that
uh we that what we were learning wasn't
being implemented
and so putting those two things together
we said it is time for us to get
our own combine because we need to show
folks
that um this isn't as horrible as it
sounds
one of the biggest problems with the
hemp industry
i'll say in new york state but it
probably applies elsewhere
is lack of good information
and more than lack of good information
um
prevalence of bad information
so you have all these people telling
stories about terrible things that
happened and scaring folks off who say
well i don't
i have enough problems i don't need that
on my plate instead of saying oh no no
look we're learning how to do this
better and since we're learning how to
do this better look now is the time to
get involved so
we need to counteract the storyline of
hemp is nothing but a problem child
right but in 2018 that was our last year
of
of working with that out of the farmer
um these are some of the nitrogen rates
that we set up
we were looking to see um how does
nitrogen
impact growth and what is
the the best nitrogen rate for this crop
um
one of the things that we found was
with poor uh nutrient
availability um and this
i guess makes perfect sense uh our crop
isn't able
to combat weeds and so in our zero
nitrogen rates and in our 50 pound
nitrogen rates although not so much in
this field because
there is leaching from the strips around
it but
certainly over here um we saw horrible
weed pressure that we just didn't see in
the rest of the field and so
the balance of ensuring proper
uh fertility will make sure that our
crop
can then out-compete the the species the
weed species that are there
we started dabbling in ndvi imaging
and it was really interesting for us our
goal was to see
if ndvi imaging could be used for
determining if nitrogen applications are
necessary
um and so here after looking at that
previous map
you can see our our low rates right our
lower rates here and our low rates here
and then our high rates in between right
the more green the more foliage there is
the more red
the more brown or um
uh uh soil is being reflected black
back excuse me so here this is at the
end of july
now here we're looking at october 5th
um
ndvi is normalized a
different vegetative index
and what it means is you're taking an
infrared image
and that the amount
of of infrared light that's reflected
back
so this is essentially a scale that
shows you how much
is being reflected back um if
there's a lot of
light being reflected back in me that's
not being absorbed
so that means that there's no plant
material there
and so that those redder areas are the
lots as being reflected that black
reflected
back the green areas is lots more
absorption
and the yellow is the scale in between
the green and the red
um so what was really interesting for us
is that
is the difference between the july image
and the october image
right you sort of you can still see
those strips a little bit but you've
sort of lost it
and the reason you've lost it is because
as the
seeds mature they're brown and so
they're going to be reflecting that
light back
but then we started thinking oh well
maybe this imaging isn't just
useful for nutrient management maybe
this
imaging might be useful for harvest
readiness
this was a a thought we had there right
again
every time we try and set out to answer
a question we get six more new ones
um and the other thing that was really
interesting
was uh in this field the left side of
the field
was one variety and the right side of
the field was
the other variety so um i actually
wrote it backwards this is the felina 32
side and this is the
uh anka side and so at the
end of june there was very little that
was established
um by the end of july we really see a
strong difference between these
these two um
varieties and then in the october image
again we can't see it anymore as we're
ready for the harvest readiness
um this field didn't get harvested there
was
so much moisture in the
um the later part of the summer and
early part of the fall
that um coordinating with
our uh person to come harvest
um we were sort of the end of the
importance list
um i'm being very diplomatic about this
and uh and therefore our crop
didn't get harvested on time um
and at the end of september
there was let's see if that's gonna let
me
i think i need to get back to my pointer
to be able there we go so at the end of
september
there was this horrible windstorm and
the crop was
more than ready to be harvested
so all of that shaking and all of that
wind
essentially put all of our seed on the
ground
so when um when
the farmer came to harvest this field
and
instead of getting between probably
seven and eight hundred pounds of grain
per acre in this field he was getting 80
pounds of grain per acre
he just gave up and said it's not worth
your time it's not worth my time i'm not
gonna do it
so um that field didn't end up getting
harvested and so we weren't able to
compare the yield results between those
two varieties which would have been
really lovely
but what we did see was the importance
of harvesting on time and we learned
that the harvest
window for hemp is really narrow um
once that seed starts to dry out it
really falls off really quickly
and so um harvest readiness
is an incredibly important
characteristic to pay attention to
when we're dealing with grain when we're
dealing with fiber as well i guess when
we're dealing with extract as well
by knowing that window is really
important
okay so um we we harvested the fiber
with a sickle bar mower and
um as you can see here
uh we were on the slope a little bit
and there was wind and the the fiber was
falling
into the standing crop there so my job
was to follow the sickle bar and take
arm fulls of the fiber and toss it
so that um we can come through and get
the
the next um
big swath cut um
that was more exercise than i think i've
ever gotten in my life
and at the very end of it when there was
just one armful
left um there was a surprise waiting for
us in the field there was
a skunk who had just walked out of its
little hole
and you know surprise saw us turn around
lifted its
tail and so i had just been throwing
these huge piles
of uh hemp so that we can come through
and cut and
um if nothing else that was a study on
the
benefit of adrenaline because i sprinted
across that field faster than i've ever
run in my life
um and the uh skunk
got the sickle bar but nothing else and
the skunk's tail is in that field and
i've been told that that tail was then
collected
and preserved but i still haven't seen
it um
so this was our first year of actually
harvesting for fiber though
and and we were learning a little bit
about it
one of the things that we did after that
was add this little
triangle to the end of the sickle bar to
make sure the fiber tips in the right
direction and doesn't fall
on the crop before it right so all of
this had to be
um picked up and thrown so that we can
continue to go through the field
um and then we let it rhett in the field
and raked it with a rotary rake and then
came through and round baled it
and we were looking for um dumbness
so totally different uh focus than with
our
our grain here we want to see the
bass fibers starting to pull away from
the herd
and we want an evenness in color we
don't want too much
of um this
dark black here with this light
here right we want that it to be much
more even there but this was our first
year and our first go-round at it
um our first trial of writing in the
field
so in 2019 we were set to do that better
um
and decided that we were really going to
split our acres
of half grain and half fiber and then
we've also
um been hearing a lot about can we do a
dual purpose
with extracts right do we have to do
our extracts production in a
horticultural style or can we do it in
the field crop style which is sort of
how they do it more commonly in europe
we tried uh a study of that um
and our horticulture department did our
our first
outdoor uh grow for
um our high cbd varieties
so we're again focusing on those
nitrogen rate trials focusing on
organic versus inorganic amendments
um and uh
oops that was 2018's drought for 20 so
what happened to 2019 weather-wise
thick 2019 was an okay growing season i
all i
i don't remember right now how can that
be
20 minutes already
all right now i know i have 10 minutes
left um
and so uh that year we found ourselves
a uh 1970
international combine and uh it took us
a little while to get it on hand so we
harvested a little bit later than we
wanted to
um so we ended up doing a bit of
harvesting by hand just to be able to
compare our nitrogen rate trials it was
really exciting for us to have
a combine of our own and be able to show
that
um this was going to be
a successful crop um and so
we did a a little bit different this
year
we had fewer uh nitrogen rates
that we did in strips in one field and
then in the field across from it
um all four quadrants
uh received manure in the winter and
early spring
and then a and b were
top dressed at our medium rate
as our inorganic field across the the
way from it was to see if that
combination of organic and inorganic
amendments was
uh better than just the organic
amendments
um and so
we also had a and d were
one variety and b and c were another
variety
because we're seeing really large
differences between varieties
um and so that this is the the way that
that map was was set up there so i'm
going to show you a couple of ndvi
images now of that
um we also um
we we do reduce tillage not really
no-till we run an airway through some of
our fields
and so there's lots of cover on the
ground and
um what we were finding was that if
there's far too much cover on the ground
you get
really poor emergence but with just
a a moderate amount of cover on the
ground our emergence was no different
than if our
um than if our field was there
so that was sort of fun for us to learn
and we also saw this is a field
after uh that was conventionally tilled
and then there was
the so it was conventionally tilled and
they planted and that same night they
had a huge rainstorm
so after that huge rainstorm you get
this surface crusting and you'll see the
only places where the hemp actually came
up are in cracks within that surface
so we really saw the importance of
planning of planting time
particularly in a conventionally tilled
soil
where you can get these surface crusts
so we were just learning left and right
everything we did was
was uh we were learning more so here
this is the image of september 3rd
um and we're comparing this image is
just your regular rgb
your regular uh picture that you could
take with your phone
um as opposed to a picture that you can
take with
um the infrared camera
um and to the naked eye you can see the
difference between what was top dressed
and what wasn't
which is sort of interesting but it's
really not as easy to see the difference
between the varieties as you can see
here
right here this showed us that this
field was too small for our strips
because there was
uh leaching in between our uh
different nitrogen rates except for this
back area here right that area with the
low nitrogen rate you can really see the
difference with the naked eye
do you need a infrared camera for that
no
right but you can see a little bit more
detail with that infrared camera
we also did a study um partnering with a
private company
to test their product to see if their
metabolism booster could take
a european cbd variety which means that
in europe if a crop produces
3 cbd it's considered a cbd variety
um so we took a european cbd variety and
sprayed it with their um i think this is
another one of them getting
my students a year ago getting the
sprayer ready um so we sprayed it with
this metabolism booster
to see uh how that would do we had some
issues that year with um
well this special variety that we bought
took
an extra month to get here so we planted
late and because we planted late the
weeds came back after killing what was
in that field with ground up it was a
mess
um so we didn't get the research results
that we wanted to from that field so we
redid it this year in the green house
right we got the harvest with our own
combine
we did the modifications to this combine
so this was a really great learning
experience for us to see what has to be
modified and what doesn't
um we only had one small fire
uh and that was easily uh doused so that
was lovely
um and this is a student walking behind
the combine just checking to make sure
that everything is flowing out of it
smoothly and our fiber harvest
um this is the the
video that folks growing for
extracts hate to see because
as that fiber falls right you can see
the clouds of pollen coming out of it
the appropriate time to harvest for
fiber is before the females have been
pollinated right we don't want the male
plants to die yet
because the male plants will die after
they release the pollen
um otherwise you lose half of your fiber
crop if you let the male plants die
and the female plants once they're
pollinated
the fiber quality changes so this is the
right time
to harvest which means there was a lot
of wind that day there was a lot of
pollen moving but
as you can see this is not a flat
landscape um how far
that pollen will travel i believe that
cornell's doing a really good job of
answering that question
but truly not as far as
folks worry i think um but you can see
that's a whole lot of pollen coming out
of that crop
but also the crop was falling straight
the way that it needed to
uh because we have that little triangle
on the end
of that's not what i want sorry
yeah there we go so again
we uh read in the field we did much
better in the second year of reading
getting a much
more even rent um and and we
bale that fiber um and in our first year
we had a little trouble with the round
baler in our second year
we learned that we needed to just do a
little bit of
protecting here of the wires that go
from the tractor to the baler and once
those
are protected everything else went
smoothly and so this was a really good
example
of where um
you have these terrible stories of doing
thousands of dollars of damage to
equipment but then you were like oh well
this wasn't hard to fix and then now
it's not a problem anymore
um so in 2020 oh we didn't grow for
grain because it's 20 20.
we uh who knew what was going to happen
and so i didn't want to set up grain
trials
um i knew i had two student interns
but i wasn't exactly positive if i was
going to be able to have them for the
whole summer
and um so we went through the easy route
we decided that fiber was the easy way
to go
um we were focusing instead of
on different nitrogen rates we were
focusing on
could we see a difference in using a
leguminous cover crop and so we looked
at cow peas and we looked at alfalfa
or sorry cover crop interpret we also
partnered with beacon skiff
and they were doing a large cbd grow
this year
and let us come in and take soil samples
and take plant samples throughout the
growing season
to see if we can track accumulation of
heavy metals
um there's been a lot of talk of hemp as
a
heavy metal uh produce or
a hyper accumulator there we go those
are the words i'm looking for
um and so that was our opportunity to to
get into that space and see if that's
true
um for two reasons one because if you're
producing an extract right would that
extract
with heavy metals in it then become
problematic or and
two to prove whether or not it really
does hyper accumulate heavy metals and
couldn't be used for phytoremediation
um man there was a lot of drought this
uh june so even though we planted
on time uh maybe a week late
our crop didn't emerge until july
because there was just no rain
um and so we went through and hand
harvested
the our plots that we wanted to but
really we just sickle barred and let the
crop lay in the field because there just
wasn't enough it was too dry a year
you can see how big my kid's gotten
isn't cute um
field uh their their cbd grow looked
really beautiful they did a great job
um and this is our fiber field on the
day it was being harvested
and this is probably the best part of
the field where
uh where my laser pointer is it's about
uh
between five and six foot tall but this
right here is only three foot tall
so it was quite a mess um we also
uh did a repeat of the metabolism
booster study but we did it in
um in the greenhouse and so
here you can see a major pest problem
that we saw and what we're waiting to
get our data back about
extracts because we noted that there
were
plants that were infested and there were
a couple of hundred plants right on top
of each other and they weren't
all infested and so we wanted to see if
whether the amount of cannabinoids being
produced
has something to do with whether or not
the plants were covered and so this is
going to be another
one of our questions of um does
uh extract concentration has something
to do with resistance to pest pressure
who knows um and then this was just
today in lab we had students doing
an uh olive oil extraction process just
to see
that there are quite a few different
ways of
extracting um uh
cannabinoids and terpenes from our
uh our plants and uh will then go
through
a distillation process so what have we
learned
uh we've learned about weed management
we've
learned that we need breeding so thank
you cornell for all the work you're
doing and breeding because
man are there a lot of traits that we're
not sure what's being controlled by
genetics what's being controlled by
environmental factors and how do those
two come together
um we know that getting nutrient
management correct
is vital not just for yield but also for
competitiveness but it's really hard
because
as so far each growing season we've had
a but
because the weather has really
interfered uh
pest pressure has really uh
been all over the place um but i think
what's
most important to me and the biggest
take-home message for me
is that um there is so much variability
here and if you're growing for extracts
you also have a fiber crop
and if you're growing for a fiber crop
um
maybe that there's also extract
potential and if you're growing for
grain what are you going to
do with that leftover fiber and so um
we need to know what is your focus for
your crop
and then um where is your crop gonna go
and before a seed or a clone goes in the
ground we need to know where that's
gonna go to
because our supply chain needs work
right
um and there are a lot of shysters in
the extract world and so you got to be
careful with who you're dealing with
um and there's no such thing as a waste
product that
um if we can develop this supply chain
better there is so much potential
for for a usable portions of this crop
um but there is still a lot of
bad information out there and the the
community at large needs to understand
that this is a crop just like any other
crop
so my funding sources
have have been sort of all across the
board
uh throughout the past five years and um
with that um i'm happy to take any
questions
um i'll start with the question jen and
first of all thank you for a fascinating
seminar and so glad that you were able
to outrun that skunk
probably one of my favorite stories so
far yes
amazing how fast we can run when
necessary
so my question for you is anytime you're
growing a cannabis
crop there are security issues
um and on a college campus
how does one alert the public
that what you are growing is a crop that
does not have
thc potential
well i started uh with signs
and then i went to all of
the professors who taught first-year
experience
courses so that all the freshmen
would hear the this is hemp for grain
and fiber
not uh anything that's going to get you
high
talk and then i went to the student
uh senate and talked to them
and i mean it really is a lot of word of
mouth and because there are a lot of ag
students on campus
they were able to do some of the
smacking upside down for me
but there were definitely students who
went into the field our first two years
and grabbed samples
and tried to sell them that was always
fun um but you know i can do as much
education as i can
and then they just have to learn on
their own that they're being found
great it was all about using my
resources on campus though
yeah sounds like you were very thorough
i would love to see
if larry smart has a question given the
work
that he's doing on cannabis
larry
hi jen thanks very much for giving that
excellent seminar
uh yeah i'm curious about your
modification
on the sickle bar mower uh
we've made some modifications to our
sickle bar more but
we don't have a baler so we haven't done
that large scale
fiber production that you have
so can you describe that a little bit
more yeah
larry it is so simple it's literally a
wooden triangle that is so if this is
the sickle bar the triangle
and and my tractors over here the
triangle comes
out a little bit and so it angles uh
so instead of being like this it's
angled like that
so as the sickle bar pushes through
the crop it's pulling the crop back
towards the tractor to fall
instead of falling back into the crop it
was it was just the simplest addition
there and it did an
amazing job um that second year our crop
was also a little bit smaller and so we
don't know if that was part of the
reason that it fell so nicely also
um but it seemed uh and this year i
don't know anyone talk about our field
this year they were so sad
um and so i i want to see next year if
it works as well again
but it was a really simple change all
right
thank you thank you
other questions for jen
yeah and i know this isn't exactly up
the alley of most of the horticulture
program where you're focused more
on the indoor grows but
i really think there is a lot of overlap
and a lot of collaboration between the
different styles of production
don maybe just uh one more quick
question jen you
said you grew some new crosses this year
can you
can you describe those a little bit more
sure so
um last year they grew
uh berry blossom and and lena 32 and
they crossed them
so that um we had a berry blossom
salina 32 cross so instead of being
tree style it was much more erect and
upright
um and so i actually just sent those out
for cannabinoid analysis
yesterday and we're we're curious
if that stays upward of
you know seven or eight percent if that
becomes a way
of being able to grow um
field crop production style instead of
horticultural production style
because that could be um cut with
a combine and and separate it out um
as opposed to uh some of the
more labor-intensive hand ways or you
know the ways that we're doing it under
a plastic
so but you got that from kailyn and dan
no we did it ourselves oh okay yeah yeah
no we did it ourselves last year
yeah so um that that
we had a student last year whose family
donated
about a hundred seats us of a bunch of
different varieties and so that's where
we got the high cbd varieties from to
start with
and then we crop we did you know our
horde department has been teaching a lot
about propagation
and um um reading
and so they did that cross and then grew
it out in the field this year to see how
it would do
structure wise great thank you
that should be fun uh any final
questions
for jen before we finish up thomas
yeah nice talk so your final point there
with uh
growers need to know who's buying what
they're
growing before they even plant it so
that's sort of a common
problem when field crop growers get into
any
horticultural crop and this one's more
challenging
and i'm curious what what the sense was
among the growers that you are working
with
um how you know
did they have some sense of who was
going to be buying it did they figure it
would work itself
out in the meantime or were there
already buyers that they just show up
like you do to a green elevator
so i had a couple of growers that were
planning on processing themselves that
had
ideas about producing their own hemp oil
and so harvesting the grain to press for
oil um
that that was the most common oh i don't
need to worry about a fire because i'm
gonna do this
um but it is such a different
way of thinking that you don't ever
worry about being able to sell corn or
soy beans or oats or wheat
like that's that's not a problem you may
not make money at it but you can always
sell
i think that it this is a two-sided
problem right one
is that there is the field crop
producers who aren't used to that
and two is the other side of hemp
production
there are a whole lot of people who have
never grown up in their life
who all of a sudden were like i'm gonna
be a farmer because hemp is legal
right so it's not that our fruit and veg
farmers
are all jumping on board because they
you're right that is part of that
production model where you have to know
where it's going
um this was more
different yeah yeah no so that
so you did get both at least both of
those audience
yes the new farm the not
experienced enough farmer and the way to
experience farmers yes
yes exactly well i'm afraid we've run
out of time but
jen this has been just delightful and
informative
and we are so pleased and appreciative
that you were
willing to share today oh thanks so much
i really appreciate you having me
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu